Mistakes make tons of mistakes made mistakes mr.
Mistakes making mistakes and make mistakes make mistake who made mistakes make mistakes what's that believe nation?
It's Evan my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe in your potential and I want to see that thing that
You have inside here come out and explode into the world to make it a better place instead
I'll help you on your journey today
We're gonna learn how to make mistakes and as always guys as you watch it
If you hear something that really resonates with you
Please leave it in the comments below and put quotes around it so other people can learn and be inspired
And when you write it down it's much more likely to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
What one thing we've failed to do in the educational system is alert people that if you're doing what no one has done before
stuff goes wrong and in fact if
Nothing ever goes wrong
In what you're doing?
If you make no mistakes in your job in your in whatever task you've brought upon yourself, then you are not on the frontier
Simple mm-hmm, it's true in science, and I heard it applied to car racing
There's a quote that I'm told spoken by Mario Andretti. He said if you are in complete control of your car
You're not in the race
Wow there's something that is just not completely in control
I like that and only then get and that's the same thing I'm
Describing for when you are on the frontier so many things go wrong when you're starting a company and often
I think people ask you know what mistakes
Should you avoid making and?
you know my answer that question is don't even bother trying to avoid mistakes because you're gonna make tons of mistakes right and the the
Important thing is actually learning quickly from whatever mistakes you make and not giving up
right and I mean there are things every single year of Facebook's existence that could have killed us or made it so that it just
Seemed like moving forward and making a lot of progress just seemed intractable
But you just kind of bounce back, and you learn and nothing is impossible
You just have to kind of keep running through the walls
you don't have to hold yourself hostage to who you used to be or
Anything you ever used to do because who has lived and hasn't made mistakes when I think about my 20s
And what a foolish girl I was and how I would give over my power to men who?
Really didn't mean me well
But now I hold no grudges against them either because I realized I'm the one who gave over the power
Because I didn't know any better and now that I know better. I know I don't have to do that again
It's one of the most powerful lessons any of us can ever know
You succeed you must first learn to fail
you know a lot of people that fail they get down on themselves, but
the
vessel sports stars learn from their mistakes
Now I should have did this okay
We'll do that make sure and just keep learning until you get to the point to where you're the champion
And then everybody needs to compete you took me eight years before I got my first championship
And after that we won three in a row lost two and I got another one
moved so it's not easy but
You know it's not a it's not a specific time period of how long it takes you deserve to learn from your mistakes
you make mistakes and then
So many people come up to me and say Gary it's so hard
I look at their Instagram
And they're not posting any of their content with hashtags
Which is a by accident way to pick up exposure in a world where they have no money?
When you have no money when I took over my dad's business it did three million dollars a year ten percent gross profit
$300,000 before expenses my first year marketing budget was fourteen thousand dollars when you have no money
And I built that business from a three to a sixty million dollar business in five years
I had to make every penny perfect, so I was right about email marketing in ninety six
And I was right and because of that I had 91% open rates when Google AdWords came out the day
It came out
I paid five cents a click
For words before anybody bid me up and I was super right and that worked if it does that lock versus preparation and do you?
Ever get anything wrong. What do you do? I can make them as high I get everything wrong
It's just that I can't recall it because once it's wrong
I'm moving on to the next thing like dwell
Dwelling on what you up on is the quickest way for the next thing not to work
Right yeah, so like so I think I do everything
I mean you know this this is a fun thing to say
some people in the back know this I was a breakout YouTube star in the first year 2006 I
Decided that the right strategy was to leave YouTube completely and go to viddler
Because viddler offered me equity in their company, and I've left an enormous amount of attention
I deviated from my intention thesis to do short-term economics and equity in a company and I lost I
Lost Wendy Brock finally came in my life two years ago
We started try to build up my YouTube for the first time
I was sitting on 40,000 user followers in a world where I could have had millions if I just stayed the course
so I make mistakes all the time, I'm
Reorganize its based on a mistake. I made the prior year
I just don't give a fuck about my mistakes everybody else cares about your mistakes if you're worried about your own mistakes. You've already lost
Making it through that first performance
I guess was in many ways a relief
But we also quickly realized there was a lot of work to be done and a lot of
Improvements that had to be made with the full-scale festival tour throughout Europe just eight weeks away well
We really had to get our grind on also super-nervous. I was like oh my god. I can't believe I'm doing this
Basically had all the festivals that we wanted that summer Tomorrowland Creamfields Lollapalooza. We had a solid plan for the whole summer
Then came the phone call hi guys we got a call from the US does I want to do support on a Rihanna tour I
Was like okay, can't say no to this do I really dare to say yes, I
Think every rookie makes mistakes and certainly so did Alan as well the big difference though
Is that most people are fortunate enough to do that within you know there are pre-production rehearsals or whatever?
Alan did it on his first show on the first leg of the Rihanna tour in front of 70,000 people I was
Lucky and actually hit the cue button on one of the songs, and I messed up
That wasn't supposed to happen
Alan in that part of his career that it was shouldn't be doing mistakes I
hate myself for every mistake that I make
But I also know that making mistakes and learning from them is an important part of the process
If I didn't make any mistakes, then I probably wouldn't have been where I am today
Every man in this room you met you blew your twenties you spend all your 30s trying to make up for the old 20s
Yeah, that's not after truth dawg every dude in this room
Blew they twenties and it thirty trying to fix what they should've did in a 20s, yeah
And so so for a song you turn 40 you're trying to recover from the mistakes you made when you 30
Now have fought it many times you start
Really at 30 you need to start buckling it on down and just realize man
everybody make mistakes
and if the mistakes you going through
Are gonna help you become the person you need to be later on Steve Harvey all the mistakes
Don't they cool to make you. I needed to mess up every marriage I
Needed to get arrested like I did I needed to get shot
I needed all this dog. I need to be homeless yeah
Because all the people that beat up man you get shot it it don't hurt it just burn that's a completely
I'm telling you
What you want? I?
Needed all them things to happen
To turn me into Who I am today so when you're young and you make mistakes don't let them eat you up
Because everybody that didn't made it that made yeah
you got to fail in order to win Hey look man to
Understand how to hit the game with a shot you got to miss the game when it shot Steve Harvey listen
What I think is important is not dwelling on mistakes and not trying to play so safe that you don't make any mistakes
I think that's the biggest thing that a lot of entrepreneurs do wrong and get wrong
They're so worried about fear and so worried about making the wrong step and making every little tiny mistake that they're spending so much time
Focusing on the negative and avoiding the negative
Instead of spending your energy you're tying your resources on the positive
And how you can do something amazing you have to understand that making mistakes is part of the process you will make mistakes
it's normal its natural its inevitable and
Through the mistakes you'll learn and keep going and make it better the next time and better the next time
And so it's adopting a mentality that make mistakes. It's okay. It's gonna happen. I've had lots of bad luck in my life
but I think
Having bad luck is equally as important because when you have bad luck in life
You have to reflect you have to take the knowledge from that experience
We've all been treated badly. We've all made mistakes
We've all had bad luck, so what we have to do is reflect take the knowledge from that experience
And then I'll allow it to enrich our life
It's as simple as that let's be honest when people say Germany regrets Marco. I say no
Because I did not be for all those mistakes. I made gonna be here
I won't I wouldn't have the knowledge that I have today. I don't have the experience that I have to because mistakes are fine
As long as you take the knowledge from the mistakes. I continually learn from my mistakes and other people's mistakes
see entrepreneurs think that hey to create that billion-dollar company 100 million dollar company or even million dollar company have to be really smart and
Sure brains is part of it luck is a huge component
But what I've learned over the years is
Everyone no matter how smart you are you're gonna fail many times, and you're gonna make mistakes
Just look at Mark Zuckerberg Facebook worked out his version of snapchat
That was a copycat did not work out right so there's other areas in which Facebook failed
But Facebook overall as a company has done great
Just because you're smart doesn't mean you're always gonna succeed with everything you try or touch
but
Every time you do something you will learn new things you'll make mistakes
And if you learn from these mistakes and avoid making them over and over again
You'll actually increase your odds of succeeding as time goes on and the best way to do
This is not just to learn from your mistakes, but it's also to learn from the mistakes of others
Rockefeller Carnegie all these people who are entrepreneurs years ago in the 1800's 1900s
They themselves use business principles and concepts that are still applicable in today's world sure we have the internet
But the same strategies and concepts that they use are still applicable right so learn from their mistakes learn will work for them
What didn't work for them? Why and?
Bring that into what you're doing today
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what did you think of this video?
What was the message that stuck most true to you?
What are you going to immediately apply somehow to your life or to your business, please leave it down in the comments below
I look forward to hearing what you have to say I also want to give a quick shout out to Celia Lopez Celia
thank you so much for picking up a copy of my book your one word and taking that picture and post it to Twitter I
Really appreciate the support, and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you. I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much. Love I'll see you soon
One of all you have the most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you Apple. That would be like a little beacon
Pay believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details